le gros problème des cyclistes et bien
c'est la peur d'être renversé renversé
par un automobiliste bien évidemment et
là il y a une solution anglaise
s'appelle spoke qu'est-ce que ça propose
Spok et bien c'est de venir communiquer
directement avec les voitures pour leur
dire je suis là je suis dans votre angle
mort j'arrive à intersection même
français pas de tuer alors vous allez
soit avoir une partie qui va être
directement dans le cadre de votre vélo
ça a un système de plus appuie sur
communiquer avec une voiture alors il
faut que la voiture en soit équipée ça
va fonctionner par de la 5G ou alors ça
veut dire communiquer directement par le
Cloud vous avez en plus une petite
lumière à l'arrière qui permet d'être vu
lorsque vous circulez ça c'est quand
même plutôt pas mal et puis vous avez
aussi un côté applicatif pour venir
communiquer directement l'idée c'est une
fois de plus de deux manières
différentes la première c'est de dire à
la voiture et bien voiture veut sortir
sur l'emplacement par exemple et bien
j'arrive je suis là donc ne sors pas ne
viens pas m'écraser ne viens pas à ma
rencontre ça va l'air tu es directement
le conducteur donc ça c'est vachement
bien et puis la deuxième solution c'est
la formation va arriver jusqu'au
véhicule qui va équiper bien évidemment
forcément et bien du même système et qui
lui dira là il y a un vélo qui va
arriver attention vous allez pas vous
rentrer dedans ça existe pour les motos
ça existe pour les scooters donc la
solution est cool d'ailleurs dites-moi
est-ce que ça pourrait vous intéresser
est-ce que vous trouvez cette partie non
marquez moi ça bien évidemment dans les
commentaires